- [Camera Man] There ya go.
- That's enough.
(record scratches)
(funky instrumental music)
- Today, we are going to be wearing
high-fashion jockstraps for the whole day.
- Hell no, I never wore
a jockstrap before.
I used to box, though.
I never wore a cup or
nothin', you know what I mean?
- I've never seen people
wear jockstraps for fashion.
I imagine I'm going to
look like a hairy stripper.
- Okay.
- Oh, my God, that is so small.
- Honestly, I like the colors.
I feel like this is the jockstrap
Captain America would wear.
- The jockstraps that I wore for hockey
were just plain white, and there was a big
plastic cup in the front.
This is nothing like that, this
is a mankini for my weenie.
- I don't see myself as a sexy person,
you dig what I'm saying,
so lookin' at this is like,
this is really uncomfortable.
- It's like a chin strap.
Hello.
- Okay, and completely naked.
- Oh, my God, this feels so uncomfortable.
I feel exposed, my culo's out.
- The only thing that's
on my mind right now
is there's a small bag
holding my testicles.
- You know, I think it's
interesting to think
that women wear stuff
like this all the time,
like really revealing underwear,
thongs, all that stuff.
- It's gonna be really
strange wearing this jockstrap
under my clothes, even
though no one can see it.
This is gonna be a mental journey
through my own comfort
level with my own body.
- I feel very uncomfortable.
People keep askin' me
what's wrong with me.
- He's such a baby.
Try wearing a thong.
- I just went to Staples.
Now, I don't really ever go commando,
but I think this is a
pretty similar feeling.
There's nothing in the back separating
my butt cheeks and my jeans
and it feels really nice actually.
- I'm about to go show my girlfriend.
She's gonna die laughing.
- I had to change out of my work clothes
into my gym clothes in the locker room
and I felt really self-conscious
'cause I was wearing the
jockstrap, obviously,
and I didn't want other
guys in the gym to see me.
And it made me realize it's kinda fucked
that I would judge someone
if I saw a guy wearing that
at the gym.
Ya know, wear whatever the fuck you want.
More power to you.
Who am I to judge?
- I'm kinda used to this jockstrap so far
'cause you can use the
bathroom without taking it off.
- Alright, so the 24 hours of wearing
the high-fashion jockstrap is over
and I actually really liked it.
It was very comfortable.
This was a wonderful
exercise in body confidence.
- I learned that I still
have a lot of insecurities
about my body, about my masculinity.
If I was completely confident
and secure in who I am
as a person, I should've
been able to wear that
and not cared at all.
If you've got the confidence
to rock a jockstrap, go for it.
You might learn something.
(mellow instrumentals)